wir reden hier ja immer mal wieder über
verschwörungstheorien und eine die
neuerdings ganz vorne mit dabei ist wird
von den sogenannten flachland verbreitet
menschen die tatsächlich der festen
überzeugung sind dass die erde nicht
rund sondern flach ist ein eisring darum
schlüssel der ozeane und vielleicht ist
über diese sogar auch noch eine
glaskuppel ohmann ihr habt euch dieses
thema whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt
jetzt alle facts zum thema was genau
steckt hinter dieser wilden
verschwörungstheorie und wie kann man
sie auch einfach widerlegen herzlich
willkommen bei distanzen fiction roman
wenn ich das schon höre ja erstmalig
auch skeptisch aber dann habe ich ganz
viele youtube videos gesehen er mensch
hier auf youtube gibt so viel viel infos
und falschinformationen nur weil
irgendjemand irgendetwas überhaupt ist
es noch lange nicht wahr
und nur weil der horizont für unsere
augen nicht gekrümmt erscheint ist die
erde noch lange nicht flach es
funktioniert einfach nicht es ist
unmöglich wenn man im netz
den begriff flatrate eingibt findet man
unzählige videos blogbeiträge oder forum
diskussion
es gibt facebook gruppen mit den namen
flache erde wissens gemeinschaft oder
flache erde gegen global es die die
nämlich an einer runden erde festhalten
werden als globus köpfe bezeichnet dort
heißt es dann
zitat unsere erde ist flach und
stationär sie rotiert nicht und ist
definitiv keine google wie man uns von
klein auf erzählt hat wir kennen die
unzähligen und nachvollziehbaren fakten
und beweise der flachen erde und die
gründe der globus lüge die seit fast 500
jahren aufrecht erhalten wird
die flache gestalt der erde setzte
kreative gestaltung und intelligente
schöpfung voraus was den menschen aber
extra verheimlicht und vorenthalten
würde
ja und die intelligente schöpfung hat
dann mal eben die naturgesetze außer
kraft gesetzt oder was auch wenn sich
die anhänger dieser überzeugung
inhaltlich nicht immer ganz einig sind
sie alle sind der festen überzeugung
verschwörer wollen das wissen um die
ware ehrt form verheimlichen ihr beweis
für die flache erde
der blick aus dem flugzeug denn dabei
ist die krümmung der erde ja gar nicht
sichtbar im netz werden bilder von einem
himmel der natürlich flach erscheint als
beweis für ihre theorie diskutiert und
über nasa bilder spekuliert die eine
runde
so zeigen und deswegen ja wohl ganz klar
gefälscht sein skepsis gegenüber allem
alle wirklich alle hinweise auf eine
runde erde werden umgedeutet oder
einfach gleich unglaubwürdig gemacht
dagegen wird jede kleinigkeit die man
als hinweis auf einen flachen horizont
deuten könnte direkt als sicherer beweis
gesät so wie es von allen
verschwörungstheorien ja bekannt ist
dagegen steht der astronom galileo
galilei der anfang des 17 jahrhunderts
gezeigt hatte dass die erde eben nicht
das zentrum des universums ist schon
nikolaus kopernikus meinte das 1992 hat
dann auch die kirche galilei
rehabilitiert denn sie hatte damals
seinen lehrern verboten dieses weltbild
können wir heute live von den
bordkameras der internationalen
raumstation iss anschauen oder wenn die
falcon heavy startet oder oder oder und
wie ihre maske letztlich fragte warum
gibt es eigentlich keine flach marsianer
und trotzdem sehen dass die flach ertler
nicht und berufen sich auf den
britischen schriftsteller samuel
robotern
er hatte 1881 ein buch namens zed tätig
astronomie globe veröffentlicht seine
frau führte diese weltanschauung fort
und gründete nach europa heimste eine
erste society die erste gesellschaft der
flachen erde wurde 1956 gegründet und
existiert noch heute
sie zählt etwa 550 mitglieder wie schon
gesagt inhaltlich sind sich die anhänger
dieser verschwörungstheorie nicht immer
einig einige glauben an eine endlose
scheibe die sich nach oben bewegt wieder
andere stellen sich einen tiefen
untergrund der ert schreiber vor alle
blätter wie die anhänger dieser
verschwörungstheorie auch genannt werden
gehen aber vom ewigen eis der antarktis
aus dass den rand der ert fläche umgibt
das zentrum der nordpol
und genau das ist in ihrer vorstellung
eben auch der grund warum das wasser von
der erde nicht ins leere feld in dem
sinne die große frage wie kann diese
verschwörung sie konkret widerlegt
werden
in der wissenschaft geht man ja nach dem
sogenannten sparsamkeit prinzip vor
deswegen gilt die beste erklärung ist
oft die einfachste auf die flache
angewandt also stellt man sich
automatisch so einige fragen wie genau
kommen die unzähligen bilder zustande
und c
die eindeutig beweisen dass die erde
rund ist so viel kann man gar nicht auf
einmal fälschen
warum gegen genau auch davon weltweit
milliarden menschen aus warum sollten
wir alle hintergangen werden und warum
ist dies noch nicht aufgefallen
wie passt das zusammen dass alle anderen
planeten kugelförmig sind nur die erde
soll es nicht sein
warum sind gerade das zentrum und der
rand also arktis und antarktis kalt
fragen über fragen und da wird es dann
ziemlich kompliziert und genau hier
geraten die flach eppler ins stocken
oder aber müssen ewig weit ausholen
das wird dann so kompliziert und
überhaupt nicht mehr einfach ich frage
mich zum beispiel wie sie erklären
wollen wie es bei einer flachen erde tag
und nacht geben kann zeitzonen und so
weiter oh mann
anstatt ganz einfach zu sagen okay die
erde ist eine kugel und nicht flach das
ist nämlich ziemlich simpel und einfach
also falls er keine videos mehr von
pixum verpassen wollt dann endet also
ich werde kein video mensa flachländer
machen also andere themen dann endet
hier meine whatsapp nummer dann erfahrt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert und zur
begrüßung gibt es ein kleines goodie
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das aber mit der genau glocke
vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit auch dafür
draufklicken kopf einschalten bei
verschwörungstheorien das hilft nämlich
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran